and the Oscar for least informed hot
take on the Academy Awards goes to I
[Applause]
[Music]
actually think I'm not that uninformed
but like I'm not an insider but anyways
I did watch the Oscars and I hadn't
thought I was gonna make this but a
couple of things happened one actually
being that I won my Oscar pool I think
16 out of 24 categories so I'm actually
going to be getting a trophy it's a bit
like the Stanley Cup every year whoever
wins you get the trophy you get to keep
it for a year so I'm gonna have to have
to make space for it when it when it's
when it's ready so that was cool and
then there's actually the oscars
themselves so if you didn't watch them
um i'll mention a couple highlights and
then i'll get into sort of the main
thing that I feel like is what most
people are talking about and it's kind
of what's been rolling around in my head
for the last about 24 hours or so and
okay so highlights Remi Malik winning
for Best Picture I'm sorry for Best
Actor that was fitting I'll remind you
though I didn't see very many of the
films that were up first stuff blackest
scene black panther win for production
design in costume that was that was
really cool to see Olivia Colman was
really kind of just really endearing
with with her clearly very flustered
acceptance speech and I I do think for
me without question the highlight moment
of the entire thing was when Samuel
Jackson got to tell Spike Lee that he
won an Oscar for screenwriting and Spike
Lee comes up and just leaps and wraps
himself arms and legs around Samuel
Jackson is it's like a nephew doing like
one
running leap hugs you know to a favorite
uncle it was like that and he's in this
purple suit it was amazing that was by
far my favorite thing that I saw um also
quite a bit of a diversity of you know
up on that stage a lot of people of
color that color being orange like the
thing that got the big focus has been
Lady Gaga who yes did look very orange
but I will point out that I think the
focus is on her because she was on stage
looking orange for a longer stretch of
time than anyone else I thought more
than a few people with George and
actually said it about several people
before she showed up on there
I think Bradley Cooper looked really
orange yeah there there were a few
others I can't even remember all of them
now but I remember pointing out at about
several people and it was yeah that was
odd
I I'm not gonna go so far as to say you
know they all had spray tans but like
there was some shade of skin tone that
the lighting that they had was not kind
to but let's get to what I think is the
biggest talking point and like I said
the things kind of been bouncing around
in my head for a little bit now Best
Picture Green Book so again I will point
out I have not actually seen green books
so when I talk about this movie and what
its win represents I am in no way
talking about the film the quality of
the film whether or not the film
deserved the Oscar I don't know I don't
have an opinion on that I haven't seen
it I know what sort of the feeling and
the consensus and the vibe is right now
but I haven't seen it so I'm not gonna
make that call um but I don't think you
have to have seen the movie to know that
this win looked bad and you know you can
say that I haven't uninformed of pain
because I haven't seen the movie but
let's be realistic
people watched the Oscars then went to
see that movie and way more people are
reading about the Oscars on social media
then watched it so I'm actually in the
majority for not having actually seen
green book
oh that's worth noting real quick the
rates were actually up this year so sure
they're happy about that
but should they go without a host again
next year anyways the okay so green book
winning here's the thing that it had
been said by in more than a few places
that this felt like a very wide-open
year as far as Best Picture goes because
there wasn't a clear-cut frontrunner and
some of the ones that might have been
the front-runner under other
circumstances had reasons that we're
gonna make it unlikely for the Academy
to select them so honestly in in a
different year or under different
circumstances I think Romo would have
been the shoo-in
Romo was Alfonso Cuaron his new movie
it's available in that place you can
watch it you know if you have Netflix
you can watch it right away I haven't
but you know it's one for cinematography
it one for foreign language film it one
for director and I think it had it been
released theatrically it probably would
have won Best Picture
but it was a Netflix release it didn't
get a proper theatrical run and there
are enough voters in the Academy who
have a either vested or philosophical
interest in preserving the theater-going
experience and they really do dread
giving too much legitimacy to streaming
and if it weren't for that I think Romo
would have won I think that would have
been an easy call as the night was going
on I was starting to think well he me
and Rhapsody might win because that had
some heat you know with the rami malek
get one
you know the sound Awards of one editing
which actually I enjoyed Bohemian
Rhapsody I would not call that a well
edited movie so that that was odd but
you know once that happened I did start
thinking I you know what that one might
walk away with it but then they said
greenbook and basically everybody at the
Oscar viewing party I was a kind of
looked at each other going wait what
I don't think greenbook was on any of
our radars like we knew it was there and
like I guess I did won a Golden Globe
but it just it seemed like such the
obvious Oscar bait movie and the Academy
has been trying desperately to get
further away from that in the last few
years I mean for God's sakes
last year's Best Picture winner was a
movie where a fish man
gets it on with a with a deaf woman you
know that's that's not what you would
think for Oscar fair and and even its
next closest frontrunner of three
billboards which I didn't like was not
typical Oscar bait so to see a real
liked by the numbers
classic Oscar bait movie take it all
felt regressive and then there's uh
there's the added context of what the
films about now I don't generally talk
about race a lot when it comes to you
know entertainment I mean I talk about
lgbtq+ representation because I'm
actually a member of that community I I
do care about racial representation but
I also figure my voice is not the one
anybody needs to be hearing on that
front you know there are people with
more information more authority works
more you know life experience who are
better off to speak than I am
but what I will say is this board more
than a passing resemblance to the wins
in 2004 for crash and in 1991 for
Driving Miss Daisy neither of which are
Best Picture wins that are particularly
fondly remembered at this point and in
many ways Green Book feels like the comp
my's winner if you don't know how the
académie voting actually works they the
voters don't just say this is best
picture they actually get a list of the
nominees and they rank them so whatever
one they rank is their number one that
gets I you know the most points I like I
don't know the the distribution of that
but like so I don't know if this is
exactly how they do it but this just to
give you an instance if there's six
nominees whoever gets the number one
spot that's six votes and then whoever
is down at the bottom they get one vote
and you know you get everybody's
rankings you assign numbers to them you
total them up
what movie had the most points and
that's your winner the thing about that
system is that it tends to work against
more daring films because more daring
films have a tendency to be more
divisive which means some people are
putting away up here but other people
are putting away down here whether it's
divisive for reasons of subject matter
or in the case of something like Romo or
I would also say Black Panther there's
something about the inherent nature of
the film or the genre or in the case of
realm of the way it was distributed that
there is a kind of a bias against within
the Academy members or at least enough
of them to throw it off and then what
ends up winning is something that was
just didn't rock the boat and sort of
most people ranked in their mid high
bracket like stuff above you got moved
round up lows but like a lot of people
put it around three or four that gave it
a consistency that carries it through
because this doesn't feel like it would
have been anyone's number one pick so if
you don't know a lot about green book a
green book is based on a true story
about a black pianist who was touring in
the south I believe it was the 50s and
he had a white driver and I think he was
also his bodyguard and while he was
touring the South he started to also
collect information for what were the
restaurant
it's hotels accommodations cetera that
were not segregated that were not
unpleasant to black people and that was
the green book that he compiled now
there's a couple of things about this
movie the first is it's been pointed out
by more than a few people it's basically
Driving Miss Daisy in Reverse this time
the white person is driving so that
doesn't look great
in addition there's bins a little bit of
if eNOS in regards to the subject matter
because the surviving family of the guy
that it's about and also nobody mentions
this one but I'm gonna say cuz I thought
it was really weird the movie so far as
I can tell is supposed to be about
marshal Ali's character he was nominated
and won for supporting actor while Viggo
Mortensen was nominated for best act
like actor and a lead role yet at most
they look like they shared equal screen
time that struck me as odd too so I
don't think that helped but anyways so
what I was saying is the the surviving
family of marsala Ali's character were
not very happy with this movie
first off turns out they actually
weren't really consulted by anybody
actually after they started saying how
much they disliked the film the official
line for most of the filmmakers was we
didn't know he had family still alive
shows you how much research they did but
apparently they were upset enough by the
end results of the film that Maher salah
ali actually on the record apologized to
some of the family members and you know
whatever you feel about the changes that
were made whether they were for the
better for the worse whether they
disrupt the integrity of the film it's
one more thing that makes this look like
maybe half lilies and what should have
been put up there and then the clincher
was actually the acceptance speech and
that was the thing like Green Book I was
like not really but like
but then I watch the acceptance and I
was like okay that's awkward
so when a best picture wins I mean the
only ones who are guaranteed to go up
there gonna be the producers because
they're the ones who actually get the
Award for Best Picture they they get the
statues but it's not uncommon for a
whole bunch of the rest of the crew
director castes screenwriters cetera to
also go up there and this kind of what
happened what became very clear is when
you looked at the cluster at the front
and who was at the mic and then who
actually gave acceptances if you didn't
already know this about Green Book it
became very clear there in a very visual
sense
oh this was another Hollywood movie
about racism with the approach of we're
all the same let's all just get along
and it was primarily made by a bunch of
aging white guys and they were the ones
who went up and spoke and it was really
uncomfortable and the NII I rewatched it
you know actually saying we are we are
all the same I'm like look I'm not I
know your hearts in the right place but
like that's that's sounding very
pandering
I'm sorry not even pandering is the
wrong word what was the word pet
patronizing there we go
that's where the patronizing coming from
you at this moment and then huh then hmm
the biggest thank you that was given and
I believe this was the director speaking
this was Peter Farrelly he gave the
biggest thank-you to Viggo Mortensen and
set and didn't just give him the biggest
things he was very he said it repeatedly
and he was very emphatic this movie
would not have happened without Viggo
Mortensen now from a completely
just business how the budgets and the
and the making of these sorts of films
go
I actually am prepared to believe that
to be factually true I'm pretty sure he
was the first big-name who was cast and
then him being attach the product help
them get financing and it got the ball
rolling and yeah maybe it wouldn't have
happened without his attachment or at
least not with the budget that it had
well again a movie supposedly about a
black a real-life black civil rights
figure in a movie made by a bunch of
white guys and those white guys giving
their biggest thanks to the white actor
who was in it it's not a great look and
actually Viggo Mortensen looked
mortified like the camera cut to him and
he looked so - he had this look of like
stop thanking me stop thanking me and it
was like and there was this there were
some other people like behind the guys
speaking who looked really tense they
seemed to ease up when he finally
thanked you know a person of color when
he mentioned Octavia Spencer who was one
of the producers people seem to like
relax a little bit like oh thank god Lee
at least he at least you didn't only
think white people but yeah the entire
thing was was not a good look and it's
not going to help the image that the
academy is a bunch of crusty white folks
and actually that's kind of a shame
because up until that wind the win of
that movie and then that speech on that
front it wasn't too bad all things
considered again I'm not gonna be a
final judge but it didn't feel as
glaringly white as it has at various
various points in various years so they
seem to be kind of getting on track and
then this
and it's the movie that deals with
racism in a way that allows white people
to pat themselves on the back because
there is a good white person in the
movie that they all get to identify with
yeah
the impression I've gotten from critics
that I trust is that as a movie it's not
as bad as crash was but it feels very
much cut from the same cloth the Oscars
did you see them what you think about it
maybe you didn't what do you think about
the results whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it whole bunch of stuff
to do
buttons links patreon P o box bla bla
bla bla bla it's all down in the
description give it a look or don't it's
totally fine if you don't cuz at the end
of the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]